elizabeth holmes was the very
personification of silicon valley the
college dropout who promised to change
the world and built a near
billion-dollar company on the back of it
confident enough in its success to say
this i'm the founder and ceo of this
company anything that happens in this
company is my responsibility at the end
of the day and i hold myself responsible
for for that well six years on a jury
agreed with her convicting her of fraud
the technology she said could detect
hundreds of diseases from just a finger
prick of blood she knew was flawed but
she continued to lie to investors about
it i don't think it was a con from the
start i i think they felt it was an idea
that could work
but just like enron you know along the
way
when it wasn't working
instead of admitting that it wasn't
working and retrenching and trying to do
what was necessary in order to make it
work if they could they pretended that
it was working the rise and fall of her
company theranos became the fuel for
podcasts and documentaries it offered a
rare look inside the world of silicon
valley startups where hype is part of
the business plan the mantra of fake it
until you make it those who've been
there say in the end you have to deliver
on that hype they're selling a vision
they're saying what the world could be
like if they're successful so there is
almost endemic to the system that need
to i don't want to say exaggerate but
really to
to tell
a narrative that's compelling to
investors but at a certain point that
has to pivot as a company gets further
along gets later stage there has to be
due diligence because at a certain point
again as the company matures
hype does have to to really uh also get
in line with credibility if not then
you're just in an instance of good
old-fashioned fraud
the question now is what if anything
will change what tharonus managed to do
was really raise a surprising a
surprisingly large amount of money
without ever really um taking the lid
off their technology i don't think that
will really fly anymore uh even in
silicon valley where um money is very
much sort of lying on the ground
are you
gonna a new tv drama based on the
elizabeth holmes story will be on our
screen soon a story of money romance
tragedy and deception its makers say for
elizabeth holmes herself the real life
drama is that she faces years in prison
greg milam sky news los angeles